this is Jason he has more than 2500 band
shirts enjoys 80s thrash metal albums
has a dog named Bella Lugosi
drinks black coffee in the morning
and I sue government agencies for
information
[Music]
I'm Jason Leopold and I'm an
investigative journalist
money laundering corruption covert
programs Secret Service visiting
celebrities I have the luxury of Dipping
my toe into any subject
I've been described as a foia terrorist
by the FBI I've also been referred to as
a member of a foia posse by the
Department of Justice and the NSA has
actually said I've weaponized the foia
team of Information Act which is
commonly known as the foia is a law that
gives you the right to access
information from the federal government
it's a half century old law often
described as a law that keeps citizens
in the know about what their government
is doing it's an incredibly powerful
tool
so I first got involved with the Freedom
of Information Act probably about 15
years ago
and really where it started to pick up
was during Occupy Wall Street I started
to file requests with the FBI related to
their role in allegedly dismantling the
encampments that were set up around the
country remarkably the FBI responds to
my foia request by stating they had no
records and they could not locate any
records so I had hooked up with a
attorney and he told me well we can sue
the agency we can sue the FBI and I was
like wait what I can sue the government
uh where do I sign up
and wouldn't you know once I sued them
they found those records that they said
they could not find
and from that moment on I just kind of
kept filing requests and suing the
government I'm constantly filing for
your requests I've easily filed more
than five thousand there are instances
where I'll be driving and I'll hear
something on the radio and I need to
pull over because I have to get the
request file really what I'm trying to
do is to pry a loose records so I can
build out investigations but also trying
to get records that would Enlighten the
public and shed light on hot button
issues
I think the foia is
underutilized by the general public
journalists only make up a sliver
of requests that are filed on the
federal level there's certainly been an
uptick in the use of foia over the past
decade or so but the majority of the
foia requests that federal government
agencies receive are from commercial
requesters people who are taking that
information and selling it they're not
requesting records that are in the
public interest they're not sharing
those records with the public the foia
request is what I refer to as a template
my template says this is a request under
the Freedom of Information Act and I
cite the law and I'm telling the agency
exactly what I'm looking for so it's a
very simple process but it can also be
painstaking and here's why agencies are
not so eager to turn over records and I
just sit back and wait but sometimes
waiting can take years
it's like Christmas when I get these
whoa
whoa U.S treasury Financial crimes
enforcement Network and this is a
request that I actually filed back in
2017. so it's taken the agency about
six years there really is no General
wait time there's more than 400 federal
government agencies so depending on the
agency the request can take anywhere
from three months to ten years the least
amount of time that I've waited for
documents was about two days I would say
that the record of documents that
arrived on my doorstep in one day was
probably about seven thousand pages from
the state department and I think that
they did that as a udemy knowing that
I'd have to thumb through each and every
page
the request that had the most impact
and I mean the most impact was for
Hillary Clinton's emails we are all
accountable to the American people to
get the facts right and it was my
request and my lawsuit that became the
vehicle by which all of Hillary
Clinton's emails were released and by
the way like I had no idea she had a
private server I was just trying to like
get the public to be like hey look it's
our emails anyway
the FBI has uncovered new evidence in
his investigation of democratic
Presidential nominee Hillary Clinton's
use of a private email server Donald
Trump is praising the FBI's decision to
review new emails another foia request
that I filed and ultimately a lawsuit
that resulted in thousands of records
that were released that had enormous
impact were records around Robert
Mueller's report into whether or not
Trump had colluded with Russia during
the campaign of 2016. I was able to get
Donald Trump Jr's name unredacted from
the Mueller report
I've gotten records from the government
where they talked about me in emails and
one time the FBI sent an agent out to
investigate one of my foia requests and
I only found out about that because I
filed a foia request with the FBI
the most rewarding part of this job has
always been holding power to account
and speaking truth to power that is
really what keeps me going and being
able to shine a light into Dark Places
foreign
[Music]